they said muslim girls are the new
Catholic girls okay and so like
basically saying that feminism is kind
of seeping into that Community too and
you're starting to get would you say
that's true absolutely because I deal
with a lot of clients and a lot of my
clients are men Muslim men and the
treatment that they get from their it's
it's different because before it would
be like look at how culture I was raised
it's like my brother gets a completely
different treatment to us so we cook
clean everything and we do everything
for him he doesn't have to do any of
that and we're okay with that we're
totally fine with that but now we're
living in a world where that scene is so
unfair whereas we kind of accept it
because we wouldn't pay for anything but
we would do all the chores and we just
accepted that and dynamic but now the
culture is you're getting to a Muslim
man and a Muslim woman raised in the
same home but getting a totally
different experience and getting really
resentful about that so the girls are
seeing that and thinking that's unfair
the men are just used to it and this
building that resentment whereas we just
accepted that's part of our bringing